oh that's a scary looking physician Jen
I shouldn't be having that for the
center was a draw
all right so how did you feel when she
did not play Queen takes off one shot
well I think you if you were watching me
on the camera so you saw some expression
on on my face when when you know um
Mitchell takes T to was played Ryan that
was my first gift
unfortunately the position is still
positionally terrible yeah the c4 pawn
is very weak did you miss him when you
play Knight g5 er you didn't see the
good defense uh of course I missed it I
wasn't gonna give up a rock Remy's rook
f3 looks like white still flowing yeah
rook f3 yeah that's the best we had
because it's not me because and even
you're threatening me at the end oh yeah
oh yeah okay I don't know what happened
to me but yeah I miss sometimes I miss
these uh well you say that you find it
yeah III think I have maybe a weakness
for that after you play 95 hit the clock
you saw immediately and you thought you
would see it but she kept thinking and
thinking I'm thinking I wasn't sure I
just thought well maybe she's savoring
the moment
not every every game your opponent gives
you a look like that
twice when else today we didn't get to
that point you had almost every move God
has suggested really yeah I mean I felt
like I was playing the first game Wow
and this game just um well of course I
miss 95 you know I missed this 95 and
the Knights coming to g4 I just didn't
and then um it was unclear I mean I
actually thought like okay I for was
kind of terrible was what I had planned
because my idea was you know there's no
night takes III because of Queen e2
Knight f4 one Knight f6 um so that's
kind of the defense I was counting on
and I underestimated that she just pins
it
pins the knight on e4 so then I know
then I noticed it that I came up with
another great defense Knight g5 I was
very resourceful in this game
but maybe I'm thinking f3 like wasn't
that like a normal-looking move f3
here yeah and I think gotta sit maybe
like Bishop e5 here for black or does
that make any sense o3 looks like a much
better move yeah I mean same ideas in
the game we could take and then play
Bishop e5 right okay right well at least
this is not like losing in the same easy
way well rook every ball is still okay
rook f3 okay yeah I mean if I would have
realized how bad it was you know I would
have searched for that defense but I
spent a lot of time so when you say that
you've missed things like Queen f1
sometimes it's a weakness in your play
do you mean yeah this guy yeah I mean I
just feel like it's not the first time
like in some somewhere I've missed that
maybe in blitz games - I I don't know
it's a familiar thing for me yeah that's
the tactic that strong players are most
likely to know really yeah well you
missed something against me and the
kings and queens that also was upset
that's right yeah some deflection or
something so so how shocked were you at
rook takes e4 in this position uh I just
took I just took the gift you know I
mean I wasn't that shocked you know I
mean anything could happen when you're
down to like five seconds of course you
know I was expecting on f6 you know and
blacks winning look at but you know it
was just uh my day to get lucky I guess
with a game that game was just of course
pure luck the first game was very nice
I'm sorry to disappoint you judge I
think I'll enjoy my afternoon I wasn't
planning I wasn't even thinking about it
because I wasn't planning on losing this
game you know but um if it was gonna
come down to it you know I would have
discussed it with my coach no I can
attest to the fact that last night you
did not study your casts openings all
night blacks leaking out the dinner
right I did come out to dinner with you
but then I actually didn't wind up
studying for a long time oh yes well I
wanted to sleep kind of had my usual
time or not at least not to too much
later than usual like probably close to
2:00 a.m. but I did actually spend
probably about three hours and the end
preparing white and black stuff so it
wasn't like I didn't prepare at all
there was a lot a lot to cover you know
when you need to do white and black for
two games and my black preparation
worked out very well
that works out great yeah just be
prepared to play the sharpest minds with
hum taking honey 495 and whatnot right
well it's not exactly her style but also
it's not just about her being prepared I
mean it's like she could play that but
obviously she wouldn't have prepared
that and I had looked at that so I know
in any case I would be more ready for
that then and you weren't surprised
therefore when she went for something
more no because it she actually had a
game like this in 2005 where she played
this into this line I mean she plays she
played their Bishop g5 here she plays
like played Bishop c2 you know a minor
difference you know reading with the
bishop but since she played that way and
she tends to like solid positions you
know that was something that was not
unexpected for me and it was you know
you got kind of a nice easy game with
black and at some point you got a chance
to take over when she sort of went
astray a little bit so not a lot of time
to look Jory eight in your victory I
know you're off to the Republic of
Georgia pretty sad right yes
when am i leaving next Saturday I'm
going to des it was in less than a week
yeah I'm going to the women's rapid and
bliss World Championship so got some
good practice for that today but I'm
really looking forward to that trip yeah
so how does it feel
finally recapturing the title after a
couple years you know I'm ecstatic to as
you see you know I'm very happy I mean
oh I'm just so happy and maybe
especially when you get a little lucky
at the end you feel your happiness is
amplified oh yeah yeah I think so I
think so cuz eat about a gift you know
I'm not sure they're always being honest
but it seems that some players when
their opponents funders say that they
they're not happy to win that way
whereas you're saying the opposite which
I feel like it might be more honest in a
way well you know when you're down when
you've been defending a position unlike
a five-second increment for many moves
and you sort of manage to consolidate a
losing position into something that
looks like a position you know and in a
way you get a little bit rewarded for
your for your defense because obviously
it wasn't even easy for me to get to
that losing position from what I had
so I feel like in some sense uh I earned
my luck a little bit but of course not
completely so when you look back in this
tournament what do you think will will
strike out to you is like the most
fantastic moment this moment
you